die erste Frage wer Lauterbach muss sein
wann haben Sie zum letzten Mal an einem
Joint gezogen und inhaliert sehr ich
gesagt sehr lange her von daher also
kann ich mich immer genau erinnern aber
ich habe es auf jeden Fall mal probiert
und es hat klassisch gewirkt es ist aber
jetzt verjährt und daher also
spielt keine Rolle wann es genau war es
geht es geht eigentlich um was anderes
es geht um die Frage ich erspare den
anderen in der Runde die Frage wann sie
das oder soll ich Jasmin
egal inhaliert nein Herbert Grönemeyer
auch selbstverständlich nicht also mal
versucht mir die die das nahezubringen
meine eigene Droge
offensichtlich ja offensichtlich ich bin
auch
rausmachen
deswegen nicht weil ich das jetzt
moralisch irgendwie Anklagen möchte
sondern weil ich gerne verstehen würde
sozusagen was sie persönlich Wissen über
die Wirkung von Cannabis Ernährung geht
es ja 50 Gramm das ist eine Menge ja wir
können natürlich die Studien und wir
sind mit Leuten aus der Szene natürlich
im engen Kontakt
Leute aus der Szene ja also das die
Szene besteht ja aus denjenigen
getroffen sind denjenigen die ja so
Handel betreiben Handel betreiben wollen
Ermittler und so weiter wir also
informieren uns natürlich sehr intensiv
und wenn so ein Gesetz dann kommt gibt
es Anhörungen mit expertenwissenschaften
und so weiter somit also es kennen gar
nicht darauf an wie viel ich jetzt weiß
ich beschäftige mich damit zwar auch
also nicht im praktischen Sinne aber wir
müssen natürlich als Bundesregierung
müssen wir uns intensivst austauschen
wir wollen wissen was tun das heißt war
ihm klar dass man mit 50 Gramm
Eigenbedarf pro Monat irgendwo zwischen
150 und 180 joints erstmal die Zahl
steht da das sind fünf am Tag ne ja die
Zahl steht also das wird so nicht von
allen Experten so gesehen wäre noch
geringere also Mengen also angegeben
aber was wichtiger ist es folgende wir
haben jetzt die Situation dass also
viele dieser Produkte toxisch sind quasi
einfach so stark mittlerweile
angereichert sind dass es nicht darauf
ankommt wie viele joints sind das wie
sondern wie stark ist so ein Joint und
mittlerweile ist der Joint zum Teil
durch die also spezielle Züchtung und
beinengung so stark dass also ein
einziger Job mehr Schaden kann als fünf
die einfach regulär mit einem
regulierten THC Gehalt auch sind gut
aber die Leute die es tun die wollen ja
die Wirkung haben ne aber die wollen
nicht sich selbst vergiften also es gibt
ganz wenige also joint Genießer sage ich
mal die sagen okay wenn das mich jetzt
vergiftet oder mein Gehirn fällt
auseinander oder das Bein gemerkt und so
das nehme ich trotzdem sondern du
würdest schon gerne eine gesicherte
Qualität haben ohne toxische
beinengungen und ohne
Konzentration das ist ja auch einer der
Gründe weshalb wir das Anliegen der
Nutzer verstehe dass man auch in diesem
Bereich wenn das jetzt schon so viel
genutzt wird eine einigermaßen gute
Qualitätskontrolle hat das nochmal die
Frage also Wein klar wie viel das ist
fünf pro Tag genau das also
die Stelle die fünf Städte das also
können ich habe das nicht erfunden weil
wir haben eine Quelle wir haben andere
aber
wir brauchen aber hier nicht über die 54
sind auch wenn es drei sind genau das
ist sehr viel ich will ja ich will ja
einräumen das ist viel ist aber ich
würde ungern jetzt hier unwidersprochen
die Zahl fünf gehen lassen sonst also
denkt jeder für Sonntag das steht so
strittig ist das meiner sichtiger aber
klar ist dass das Mengen sind die und
sehr ungesund sind wenn man jeden Tag
konsumiert raucht tatsächlich die 50
Gramm im Monat weg das ist extrem
ungewohnt
oder nicht aber die Frage ist trotzdem
warum gibt man so viel frei ja wenn ich
das nicht mache dann sind diejenigen die
besonders abhängig sind die jetzt schon
die bleiben dann weiter auf den
schwarzmarktprodukten Hängen und haben
das Problem was ich gerade also
verhindern will dass Leute halt
übergehen oder sich zum Beispiel beim
Schwarzmarkt bedienen und auf dem
regulären Markt also wenn ich jetzt das
Problem sagen wir hätten gesagt zehn
Gramm dann hätten die Leute die zehn
Gramm genommen oder von uns vielleicht
gar nichts also vom legalen Kauf und
hätten wird der Schwarzmarkt wäre
geblieben mit allen Problemen toxische
Substanzen Beimengungen viel zu hohe
Konzentrationen und so weiter ich kann
weniger machen dann löse ich aber das
Problem nicht ich ähm ihren Experten von
vom UKE hier in Hamburg Leiter der
suchprävention nicht irgendjemand reiner
tomasius der sagt 50 Gramm das ist eine
Dealer Menge ja das ist eine hohe Menge
dass ich kenne Thomas ist und schätze
sehen und wir sind tatsächlich damit im
Bereich wo man sagt wenn ich 50 Gramm
legal erwerben kann dann brauche ich als
Person keinen Schwarzwald mehr
weil es so viel ist weil so viel ist
genau wenn ich also jemand wenn jemand
so alt Pflanzen auf dem Balkon ja drei
Pflanzen die meisten die also sagen wir
50 Gramm Weg Rauchen die werden keine
Pflanzen aber es sind meistens sind
wieder Leute die Pflanzen nutzen oder
die kaufe gute mal 50 Gramm braucht man
auch keine Zeit mehr für Pflanzen das
auch aber das sind alles das sind
ehrlich gesagt andere Kunden der
Pflanzen mensch das ist derjenige
gelegentlich was nimmt aber derjenige
der jetzt abhängig ist ich bin ja damit
beschäftigt den Menschen die abhängig
sind die süchtig sind den will ich eine
gesicherte Qualität darstellen und
verneinen dass die vergiftet werden oder
sich selbst vergiften dass dich ständig
mit Kriminellen zu tun haben dass sie
dann noch in andere Drogen überführt
werden wenn ich diesen Leuten also
begegnen will und da bin ich der Meinung
ich kann ja ihre Position auch man muss
man sich in der Politik ehrlich machen
man vermeidet eine polemische Diskussion
man bringt die Faxen auf den Tisch und
sagt ich kann das Problem nicht lösen
indem ich zu wenig anbietet was ist denn
ihre Position dazu fragen darf
sich die Bundesregierung in der
schwierigen Situation befindet dass
einerseits hier ein Wahlversprechen
eingelöst werden soll das persönlich die
Süchtigen betrifft sondern vor allem
eher junge Menschen oder Menschen die
sagen dass diese Droge in einem Land in
dem Alkohol und Nikotin so normal ist
dann kann auch Cannabis legalisiert
werden dass man das irgendwie bedienen
möchte aber dieser relativ schnelle Wurf
der ja auch viel abgespeckter ist als
das was im Oktober erlebt haben
zeigt ja eigentlich dass wir gerade voll
also dass sie versuchen einerseits
irgendwie Süchtige präventiv aus der aus
den falschen Stoffen rauszuholen aber
andererseits einen marktbefeuern von dem
wir eigentlich wissen dass
Cannabis per se ja nicht ich muss mit
Daniela Ludwigs Worten zu sagen kein
Brokkoli ist
und ich jetzt irgendwie das Gefühl habe
okay man möchte hier vielleicht eine
Wahl gewinnen irgendwann auch mit dem
Statement wir haben es stückweise
legalisiert nee das meine ich gar nicht
Probleme sondern man bedient hier eine
Zielgruppe aber Sie müssen natürlich als
müsste so argumentieren dass sie sagen
wir haben die richtigen im Blick und wir
haben die Nebenwirkungen im Blick aber
da ist 50 Gramm natürlich trotzdem eine
Summe von der man sich fragt ob es nicht
andere Dinge beachtet in ihrem
Freundeskreis wie diskutieren Sie das
ähm
also die Menschen die Cannabis
konsumieren die sich das es gibt ja zwei
Kategorien es gibt einmal die Menschen
die günstiges Gras auch beziehen weil
sie sich auch teures niemals leisten
können würden da können wir bestimmt
noch zu wie die Preise sind wenn es dann
legalisiert ist und dann was in der
Mittelschicht gerne gängig ist Menschen
die das halt zum Genuss konsumieren oder
was irgendwie cool ist oder wo man das
auf Partys macht
und es gibt halt die die es halt ich
finde es ich bin nicht gerne dabei wenn
es passiert aber ich habe die Meinung
jeder soll machen wie er möchte ähm aber
unter jungen Leuten gibt es glaube ich
einmal die Frauen die überhaupt nicht
interessiert weil sie sich konsumiert
und die anderen die so sagen sie können
nicht verstehen warum ist noch nicht
legalisiert ist weil es ja völlig normal
ist er wird wie schaust du auf diese
Debatte die Debatte ist ja wirklich alt
ne die gibt's seit ewigen Zeit und ich
habe dieser Tage interessanten Begriff
dazu gelesen prohibitions Dilemma ja das
heißt du hast als Stadt hast du
eigentlich zwei Möglichkeiten entweder
gehst du mit sehr hohen Aufwand gegen
etwas vor was viele Leute offensichtlich
machen wollen oder aber du erlaubst es
und versuchst es in irgendeiner Form zu
kontrollieren aber du kommst aus der
Nummer nicht raus weil die Leute es so
oder so machen also erstmal sage ich Ja
zu vielen Dingen gerne was und ich habe
auch von einigen Dingen auch Ahnung ob
ich heute für manche Dinge auch keine
Ahnung ich glaube die
Entkriminalisierung ist elementar das
halte ich für ganz elementar was die was
die Menge angeht man weiß dass ihr THC
Gehalt wohl enorme Psychosen auslösen
kann auch unter speziell auch zwischen
18 und 25 ist der Punkt das ist der das
ist eine elementarer Punkt ich glaube
das ist dass die Frage warum macht man
sich ab 25 aber ich muss fairerweise
sagen das ist eine Debatte wo ich eher
glaube da bin ich vielleicht nicht der
ganz zentrale das ist glaube ich so dass
das Wichtigere Thema was was bedeutet
das was bedeutet das war zwischen 18 und
25 weil das Argument ist von von
namhaften Urologen die sagen die die
Reifung des Gehirns ist sozusagen erst
mit 24 25 wirklich abgeschlossen davor
kann es massive Schäden geben deswegen
warum die 18
ein Satz nur bevor ich dazu komme mit
diesem Gesetz werden wir keine Wahlen
gewinnen und das soll nicht vorgesehen
und das ist auch sicherlich kein Gesetz
wollen Gesundheitsminister weil mit
Gewinnen das ist aber nicht beabsichtigt
ich will den Konsum sichern machen und
zweite Punkt ist also wenn wir jetzt die
Möglichkeit hätten wenn wir sagen wir
machen das jetzt silikal ab 25 und die
unter 25 würden dann sagen na gut dann
konsumiere ich bis 25 gar nicht und
warte bis ich das legal konsumieren kann
und schone mein Geld das würden wir
sofort machen aber das ist eine Welt die
ist nicht gibt die Welt ist gibt es eine
andere die Schäden kommen gerade bei den
18 bis 25 jährigen und wenn ich dann
diese weiter den toxischen Beinen und
Konzentrationen des schwarzmarkts
überlasse dann überlasse ich
ausgerechnet diejenigen die am meisten
den Schaden nehmen dem unregulierten
Markt den größten Schaden macht somit
also muss man sich ehrlich machen wenn
ich dieser Gruppe helfen will muss ich
die mit auf weil sie helfen den doch
nicht indem sie dann 50 Gramm als
Obermenge freigeben niemand gibt jetzt
es geht doch keiner hin und sagt ich
rauche Art wie eine Gelegenheit
Konsument der jeden Tag anschauen
der sagt jetzt plötzlich mein Gott ich
sehe der Minister erlaubt 50 Gramm dann
rauche ich jetzt 50 Gramm sondern der
wird weiter jeden Tag vielleicht einen
join Drachen viel zu viel aber hat dann
eine Qualität wo der THC gehabt
niedriger ist und wo darüber hinaus auch
bei mengungen nicht dabei sind womit der
Dealer Versuch den abhängig zu machen
zum Beispiel von einem Vitamin
Amphetamin z.B in den joints ist oftmals
damit versucht der Dealer zu erreichen
dass der Amphetamin Konsum entweder
ersetzen oder zusätzlich kommt dieses
Problem sehen wir und die also Folie auf
dem das ganze ja machen ist wir sehen
mehr Kriminalität bei den 18 bis
25-Jährigen
Beschaffungskriminalität wir sehen mehr
Konsum wir sehen mehr Konsum bei den
unter 18 jährigen ja soll ich denn jetzt
sagen das Thema ist mehr als Minister
unangenehm und ich bleibe bei der
Prohibition und überlasse das alles den
Diener versuchen beides es gibt ja auch
das Thema zwischen 15 und 18 ja da
wollen wir schlicht und da kommt eine
Legalisierung natürlich überhaupt nicht
in Frage da bleiben die Strafen so hart
wie sie sind oder werden verschärft das
wird noch zu prüfen sein und da ist das
komplett illegal und da kommen wir mit
einer
intensiven Kampagne weil was junge Leute
nicht wissen ist tatsächlich der oft
bleibende Hirnschaden wenn man in der
Jugend Cannabis konsumiert selbst in
Mengen wo der Leier glauben würde das
ist harmlos meinetwegen einmal pro Woche
da wird der Leihe glauben das macht beim
jungen Menschen nichts aus aber es ist
nicht so sondern damit wird es gern
beschädigt und dann darüber wollen wir
aufklären und das ist auch der Grund
übrigens wenn das weshalb das Gesetz bei
mir ist beim Gesundheitsminister weil
ich das alles erklären kann und auch
muss in der Sache und es ist nicht
meinetwegen also bei jemandem beim bei
der Kulturministerin oder was weiß ich
oder es beim Wörtchen nicht beim
Wirtschaftsminister sondern auch nicht
beim Finanzminister dass der Steuern
haben will das Gesetz ist bei mir weil
meine Pflicht ist es die Risiken auch
für junge Leute klar zu benennen und zu
bekämpfen sie sagen gerade zwischen 18
und 25 ist es gefährlich sie sagen jetzt
faktisch und so ist das Gesetz angelegt
zwischen 15 und 18 ist es quasi
Teufelszeug dann ist es super gefährlich
und ab 18 ist es nur noch gefährlich das
Gehirn wächst also je mehr das Gehirn
quasi gereift dass desto geringer ist
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass der Schaden
kommt würde man jetzt zum Beispiel mich
fragen Mediziner sie sind Arzt aber
Gesundheitsminister sie werden dafür
bezahlt Schaden von diesem Land von
seiner Bevölkerung abzuwenden speziell
auch von jungen Leute und ich weiß dass
ihnen wirklich intrinsisches Anliegen
fühlen sie sich wohl dabei wenn Sie
jetzt das so frei geben ich habe zu
wählen zwischen einem übel und einem
größeren übel das Übel ist ich werde
damit leben müssen dass 18 bis
25-Jährige Cannabis konsumieren und sich
damit schaden und demnächst wird es auch
noch Cannabis sein für dessen legale
Verbreitung ich mitverantwortlich bin
Überzeugung oder ist das etwas was sie
umsetzen weil sie Teil dieser Koalition
sind weil sie getrieben werden an dem
Punkt
ob ich das umsetze weil ich getrieben
bin weil da die meinetwegen das war sich
die Grünen mit der Pistole hinter mir
sitzen und so das ist nicht der Fall
aber dazu komme ich gleich aber bevor
ich sagen kann ob ich zu etwas getrieben
werde möchte ich sagen was ist denn
überhaupt wäre und das sind zwei übel
ich akzeptiere 18 bis 25 der Konsum
steigt die Dosen sind toxisch bei Menge
und Amphetamine Kriminalität junge Leute
werden vorbestraft und so weiter alles
sehr schlecht oder ich versuche das zu
begrenzen indem ich das legalisiere in
dem ich die Ware kontrolliere den THC
ergat in dieser Gruppe zum Beispiel
runterfahren die Kriminalität wegbekomme
dann ist es zwar ein kleineres Problem
aber mein Problem oder ich lasse es groß
wie das zum Beispiel also aus meinem
Verständnis aus Markus Söder macht da
sagt es mir doch egal wie groß das
Problem ist solange es nicht meins ist
und das finde ich ist nicht die Art und
Weise wie ich das machen kann also ich
finde es halt nur interessant nimmt also
das ist jetzt auch richtig gemeint
das ist Fragen besser fragen Sie das
jetzt
interessiert mich eigentlich warum warum
das jetzt so schnell passiert also weil
die der Gedanke mit dem Modell dass sie
vorschlagen dass ich zum Beispiel am
spanischen Modell orientiert das ist
jetzt ziemlich naiv zu denken dass die
Entkriminalisierung dann stattfindet
weil es gibt zwei Dinge die glaube ich
im Diskurs nicht so ähm präsent sind
junge Menschen die Cannabis konsumieren
und gehen mir mal das Modell rein wie
die Finanzierung stattfinden soll und
auch wenn wir diese diese Clubs dann
haben in ersten Säule die dann dafür
sorgen dass Menschen eine Mitgliedschaft
haben sich dort dieses Cannabis besorgen
können das werden Menschen sein die
Zugänge dazu haben werden die das
gewisse Geld haben werden weil auf dem
Schwarzmarkt ist es irgendwas zwischen
sechs und neun Euro und es wird niemals
der Preis sein den man in diesen Clubs
verlangen kann für das was man dort
bekommt das sauber ist plus die
Produktionskosten weil dieses Gras muss
ja auch irgendwo herkommen und das ist
ja etwas teurer als wenn man es halt aus
irgendwelche Strukturen hat das heißt
ich frage mich ein bisschen warum ist es
jetzt so schnell passiert wenn es kein
wahlkampftaktischen Grund hat dass man
sagt wir haben irgendwie sowas Halbes
und nichts Ganzes es gibt noch keinen
Anschein davon was diese
Präventionskampagne beinhalten soll und
jetzt stehen wir hier und es ist
irgendwie so halb es kommt aber es kommt
auch nicht und es enttäuscht sozusagen
eigentlich die Konsumenten ist einfach
so kaufen wollen die Unternehmer die
sich seit Jahren vorbereiten damit hier
zu handeln und irgendwie auch
letztendlich die generell Erwartung weil
die EU muss das ja auch noch absegnen
und das sieht ja auch nicht gut aus ja
so viele Dinge wurden genannt erstmal
muss das was wir jetzt machen von der EU
abgesegnet werden diese Clubs wo das
dann angebaut wird ohne Profil und so
weiter und so dass die schnelle Antwort
das muss die EU gar nicht absegnen von
daher haben wir da gar kein Problem zum
zweiten weshalb kommt das so schnell
darüber kann ich nur müde lachen ich
arbeite an dem Gesetz mit fünf anderen
Ministerien seit einem Jahr aber es ist
ja noch nicht fertig also sie können
sagen das sind die Idee
ich wünschte wir wären schneller davon
gar keine Rede sein also wir arbeiten
jetzt seit einem Jahr daran und ich
hoffe dass du damit bald auf die Fläche
kommen wir haben also in den nächsten
Tagen wird der also Entwurf durch die
also Ressorts gehen dass ich die anderen
Ressourcen damit beschäftigen das ist
jetzt fertig ich habe zufälligerweise
heute Nachmittag noch mal also an dem
Gesetz also an dem Entwurf gearbeitet
von da weiß ich relativ genau also wo
wir in der Zeit stehen noch vor der
Abreise und
jetzt eben zu der Frage also was wie
wird das mit dem Preis kommen dann muss
man vorsichtig sein wir überlegen uns
natürlich wie der Preis sein muss damit
wir tatsächlich den Schwarzmarkt
Austrocknen wenn der Preis denn die also
wenn das sozusagen also jetzt gehandelt
wird dann ist das Preisproblem ein
Problem aber diejenigen die jetzt in dem
Club sind das sind ja Mitglieder wenn
man sie mal baut ja füreinander an und
da gibt es dann eine Gebühr für das
einmal kurz erklären die Idee ist der
Club ist gerade gefallen wie soll das in
Zukunft konkret laufen Clubs von bis zu
500 Leuten bis zu 500 Mitgliedern wo
diejenigen die das dann machen bestimmte
also
Voraussetzungen erfüllen das heißt wir
müssen wir müssen einen einen Club haben
wir könnten jetzt noch keinen Club
gründen weil wir sind jetzt hier 4
Personen könnten also der Club hat bis
zu 500 Mitgliedern die Mindestzahl der
Mitglieder die einen grub Gründen kann
kann ich heute noch nicht sagen weil
dann kann ich das Gesetz ja auch
ausplaudern und die treffen sich dann
zum Kiffen nein überhaupt nicht das ist
was anderes was wir nicht wollen sind
also solche
Beispiel in Holland oder also in anderen
Ländern wo man sich zum Kiffen trifft
sondern der Club ist im Prinzip eine
anbaugenossenschaft und diese
anbaugenossenschaft wird überwacht und
dort wird die Qualität gesichert dass
zum Beispiel nicht die hohen Dosen darin
sind keine beinengungen und so weiter
anbaugenossenschaft also da tun sich
Leute zusammen genau züchten genau jeder
arbeitet mit aber da eine mehr oder
andere weniger und dann also wird er
dort angebaut für die Mitglieder man
darf nicht verkaufen an Dritte nicht
Mitglieder können nichts bekommen
diejenigen nur Erwachsene können
Mitglied sein über 18 und so weiter und
dann wird dort der Anbau
quasi zum Selbstkosten deckungspreis
reguliert und die Mitglieder haben
Anspruch auf eine bestimmte Menge 50
Zimmer Max nicht 50 Gramm maximal 50
Gramm sind es Leute unter 25 sind es
übrigens nur 30 Gramm das wollte ich
auch noch sagen okay Menge ist nur aber
und somit ist das nicht so dass ich da
Leute zum Kiffen treffen oder das
irgendetwas bei der EU für dich tun und
handeln und die Handeln nicht sondern
sie sind Mitglieder im Club und wenn ich
jetzt in einem Mitglied in einem Club
bin und bezahle eine Gebühr dafür und
bekomme dafür die Ware die im Körper
also sozusagen angebaut wird dann ist es
kein Hahn wenn ich jetzt im Club in
meine Entwicklung Bochum bin weil
Herbert Grönemeyer heute hier ist kann
ich dann auch gleichzeitig in einem Club
in Berlin z.B das kauft dort auf
Dienstreise
dann wären ja diese Mengen die eben
angesprochen werden die werden ja
überhaupt nicht kontrollierbar nicht
halten aber wer soll das Kontrollieren
Herr Lauterbach das ist auf jeden Fall
gar kein
kontrollieren im Vergleich zu dem
gigantischen kontrollhaus funktioniert
ja auch nicht den wir derzeit machen und
wo wir keine Erfolge haben wir denn
jetzt wir haben jetzt überall Kontrollen
wir haben jetzt riesige
Ermittlungsverfahren die Gerichte sind
also überlastet es gibt etliche
vorbestraftete also wenn ich hier von
control Kontrolle spreche die jetzige
Kontrolle ist doch mega teuer belastet
die Polizei funktioniert
und funktioniert nicht wenn es jetzt so
wäre dass sie in einer magischen Welt
wären und die Alternative wäre zwischen
meinem Modell und die also Leute
konsumieren nicht mehr wenn diese
magische Welt also bestimmte im Sinne
eines Gedichtes von Neruda oder was dann
also dann also können wir das machen
aber es gibt ja nicht zu 500 Leuten dort
soll kontrolliert werden keine Abgabe an
unter 18-Jährige nur 30 Gramm bis 25
und genau Abgabe Menge alles wird
festgelegt alles wird alles du musst
Mitglied sein und so weiter genau noch
mal die Frage wer soll das kontrollieren
wer noch überhaupt nicht das Personal
und die Ressource um das wirklich zu
machen da ihr die Landes die Länder
bestimmen dafür Behörden das machen aber
jetzt mal zum Vergleich was ist denn
einfacher und was ist sozusagen
effizienter ob ich einen Club
kontrolliere und meine wegen drei oder
vier Leute die das dort machen und mache
dort Stichproben oder ob ich die 500
Leute kontrolliere die im Club Mitglied
sind die bisher auf der Straße kaufen
und sich dabei verunreinigt dieses Zeug
kaufen und die jederzeit gefährdet sind
in diesen Vereinen einen
präventionsbeauftragten geben wird dazu
kann ich also nicht Stellung nehmen
sicherlich ist der präventionsstand sehr
sehr stark wird stark kommen dafür
zeichne ich dann auch verantwortlich für
Jugendliche und für diejenigen die
von der Abhängigkeit ferngehalten wird
an ganz zentrales Thema wird sein das
ist ja so das was mich auch in anderen
Zusammenhängen immer sehr stark
interessiert die neurologischen Schäden
ich habe ja auch bei kovic sehr häufig
darauf hingewiesen wenn man dort
erkrankt neurologische Schäden sind
keine Seltenheit und so weiter für mich
ist es bitter mit anzusehen dass zum
Beispiel Kinder die also auch wenig
gekifft haben ein viel geringeres also
Bildungsniveau erreichen und dann
beispielsweise auch in der Universität
oft nachher überhaupt nicht so gut klar
kommen und keiner weiß woran das liegt
das heißt ich will hier auch
Bildungschancen also erhalten ich will
aufklären und der beste Konsum unter 25
bleibt gar kein Konsum
sie sagen wir werden Jugendlichen mit
einer großen Kampagne erklären es gibt
eine viel geringere Wahrscheinlichkeit
Abitur zu schaffen weniger häufig
studieren werden oft mit der Sucht nicht
klar kommen meine wenn man das alles so
hört das ist ein Gruselkabinett so so
eine Horrorvisionen die da war wird das
heißt bis 18 erklären sie den Leuten das
um ihn dann zu sagen ab 18 ist es okay
aber was ist daran das funktioniert
ehrlich gesagt was glaubwürdigkeit ist
das Stichwort was ist daran das
Besondere wir müssen doch ehrlich machen
all dies könnte ich auch in geringerem
Maße über Akkus sagen und also obwohl
das ist kein argumental Lauterbach
sondern alle saufen müssen ne also das
ist kein Thema bevor ich das Argument
überhaupt bringe wird schon gesagt es
gibt hier kein Argument das ist ja wenn
ich nicht überzeugen das war rhetorisch
eine Minderleistung jetzt kommt meine
Argument okay dann wiederhole genau und
dann wird dann argumentiert dass ein
schlechtes Argument oder gar
aber ich konnte das Argument ja noch
nicht bringen und das Argument ist also
Alkohol ist auch auf der von der Menge
ein Gramm ein Zellgift fürs Gehirn
Alkohol ist immer ein zeltgift also
jedes so argumentiert da kann ich auch
sagen ja wenn Alkohol ein zähl Gift fürs
Gehirn ist wieso ist er das dann
überhaupt erlaubt wieso also lassen wir
denn dann zu dass die Menschen überhaupt
in die Sucht kommen und so weiter auch
eine gute Frage
gute Frage ist war so ein gutes Argument
ähm nein das Argument das ja häufig
vorgetragen wird ist ja wir machen das
deswegen weil wir ein gewisses
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem haben so nach
dem Motto die verdient ja auch an
Alkohol das besteuert ihr der Staat
verdient sehr viel Geld mit der
sogenannte Abhängigkeit von von Alkohol
mit Alkoholismus wenn man sowas habe ich
ja nie gesagt und übrigens oder dieser
Lösung die wir jetzt bringen wollen also
diese Clubs dieser anbaugenossenschaften
der Steuerzahler der Fiskus verdient gar
nichts also wir machen das ja so dass
das also zum selbstkostenkreis dann
gemacht wird und also der also Christian
Lindner geht leer aus und ob mit einer
Säule
wenn es darum also das meine ich es ist
das meine ich das war der Punkt vom
Anfang es wird so ein bisschen wie alle
befriedigen wollen aber es funktioniert
nicht ganz und der Punkt ist ja aber
wenn sie Alkohol nennen also wir haben
eine Gesellschaft sie haben ja als
Gesundheit auch viel zu tun das weiß ich
aber wenn man einen Punkt ist wo
bestimmte Drogen wie Alkohol schauen wir
mal das Skandinavien eine andere Länder
wo das ganz anders wird Nikotin und
Alkohol dass wir jetzt die nächste
Drogerie legalisieren mit dem Blick
darauf dass wir endkriminalisieren ich
muss ehrlich sagen es die meisten Leute
werden nicht in diese Clubs gehen die
werden sich denken wir haben ja auch so
Grenzen in Berlin z.B 7 Gramm darf man
mit sich führen dass es dann irgendwann
im Verfahren dazu wahrscheinlich kommt
dass es wieder eingestellt wird dass die
Leute werden doch tendenziell eher
wieder für 8 € bei ihrem Dealer kaufen
wo sie wissen okay das muss jetzt noch
nichts passiert weil das eine
Vertrauensfrage ist und das heißt wenn
ich weiß ich kriege es schnell am Kotti
halt mein Zeug aber dann ist es ja dann
also dann ist es naiv zu denken dass die
Leute auf einmal alle im Club gehen
werden
also die Händler und die Spezialisten
die finden den Gedanken gar nicht naiv
also wenn ich zum Beispiel ein junger
Mensch wäre ich würde studieren und also
wird tatsächlich einmal oder zweimal pro
Woche
konsumieren wenn ich das also sie würden
sich als Kiffer dann registrieren lassen
dass ich dann machen würde das ist mir
doch tausendmal lieber wenn ich legal
registriert bin als dass ich überlege
und werde dort von einem heroiden
abhängigen sechs Jahre schon da Cannabis
kaufen und wissen das ist rein und ist
nichts passiert und es ist 7 €
günstiger Punkt man könnte sagen das
Zeug am Gott die bleibt billiger ich
kenne den Dealer schon lange jetzt
bleibe ich auch bei dem der Club
interessiert mich nicht ich glaube das
ist nicht so also das sagen auch die
Experten weil viele werden ja hören das
Zeugnis für unrein wenn ich über den
Kotte gehe ich bin dass es ein oder
andere mal und schaue mir die Dealer
dort an die ihrerseits typischerweise
ruinabhängig oder was auch immer
abhängig sind dann würde sich der ein
oder andere denken wenn das jetzt hier
so zu beschaffen ist ohne dass das also
illegal wäre und ohne das beinengungen
sind und so weiter da gehe ich doch
nicht mehr zu dem
typenschichtkonzept das ist das was ich
am Anfang meinte also für Menschen die
Konsum vielleicht auch sucht gründen
oder die ähm das günstig erwerben um
ihre Probleme auch also Menschen die das
die das Rauchen auch um ihre
alltäglichen problemlos vergessen das
ist ja auch nicht so das Cannabis nur
Genuss ist sondern ist ja für Menschen
auch ein Mittel um dem Alltag zu
entfliehen das heißt da vergesse ich
eigentlich schon wieder eine
ärmere Gruppe und die Kriminalität
vielleicht unter Menschen die davon
abhängig sind und auch ihren
Freundeskreis die aus der gleichen
Schicht kommen vielleicht wenig
Einkommen haben das sind ja auch alles
Mechanismen die muss man eigentlich mit
einrechnen natürlich werden irgendwelche
Abiturienten die 18 sind
das finde ich also wir sprechen
gegenschätzung also ich habe das
Beispiel mit dem Studenten jetzt
gebracht weil ich mich selbst also dann
eher als Student gesehen hätte aber wenn
jetzt einmal nicht wegen
Heizungsinstallateur der auch ab und zu
konsumiert weil das ist auch in diesem
handwerkerkreisen gibt es auch der ist
genauso schlau wieder also Studierende
und sieht sich den Typen am Corti an den
drogengängen zu tun aber der Zugang ist
doch da wenn ich in den Club jetzt hier
also aufgenommen werden kann das kostet
doch nichts ich muss doch nichts
bezahlen das ist eine billige Gebühr
werde
aber wenn ich das letzte sofort passiert
das nicht sondern ich sage das dass die
Experten mit denen wir uns beraten sagen
und mir kommt es nicht gesagt plausibel
vor wer ist denn so dumm und geht zum
Kotti wo er schon fast ein paar Mal
rausgeraubt worden wäre wo der Diele
aussieht als wenn er demnächst sterben
müsste und wo ich dann
illegal kaufe der weil ich mich hier
also in einem Club versorgen kann wo ich
legal also am Kotti nicht nur Menschen
die am Ende sind und da sind auch
Menschen auf also Menschen die Existenz
ein einen Punkt nochmal eben schnell
machen was ich so interessant finde also
sie machen das ja gemeinsam mit der FDP
vor allen Dingen auch auf Betreiben der
FDP nein das ist das ist falsch das ist
ein Projekt auf Betreiben der FDP
betreiben ist das wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag beschlossen auf jeden
Fall dazu gehört auf die FDP genau das
ist aber beschlossen worden in der
Arbeitsgruppe Gesundheit also ist jetzt
nicht so beschlossen worden im
Koalitionsvertrag meinetwegen
ich hatte eben einen Scherz gemacht
hinter dir das war kein Wahlkampf
sondern waren witzig aus ich würde
vertragen mich gut miteinander alles gut
das ist hier nicht ich gehört zu
denjenigen die nicht jetzt hier an
länderbecher es waren Witz mehr war das
nicht aber wir haben uns tatsächlich
beschlossen im Koalitionsvertrag in der
Arbeitsgruppe gesund genau und von daher
hat das nächste der Punkt ist das aus
findet die FDP der Datenschutz sonst
immer so unvorstellbar wichtig ist wir
nachher auch noch mal über
Digitalisierung und so weiter sprechen
die lässt dann Kiffer registrieren ja
das ist kann während doch nicht
registrieren trinke werde ich nicht
registriert ich bin dann in einem Club
Mitglied habe ich doch nicht registriert
durch diese Daten gehen noch da muss ich
Mitglied werden Namen abgeben
Datenschutz und registrieren so dass
suggeriert jetzt als wenn beispielsweise
der Staat oder das Land oder irgendeine
Behörde die Mitglieder bekäme aber das
ist ja nicht so sondern ich bin in
dieser Genossenschaft dann Mitglied und
das wissen die anderen Genossen die mich
aber dann beim Einkaufen und Konsum auch
sehen also müssen doch wissen ob jemand
nicht in Mannheim Berlin und in Hamburg
gleichermaßen Mitglied ist also wir
haben Entschuldigung mit diesen Daten
irgendwas machen sonst ist es ja es ist
Polizei kontrollieren das ganze
beispielsweise jemand also mit 50 Gramm
also erwischt wird und sagt dann ich
habe die 50 langsam aus meiner
Genossenschaft dann ist natürlich
derjenige der die 50 km hat und
behauptete sei in der Genossenschaft in
der Pflicht darzustellen was ist denn
das für eine Genossenschaft wo sind sie
denn da Mitglied und so weiter und wenn
das nicht der Fall ist dann würden wir
davon ausgehen die Genossenschaft wo er
Mitglied es gibt es nicht er hat gekauft
und so weiter und dann kommt es darauf
an wie viele haben kann und so weiter
aber es ist doch nicht so dass ich jetzt
eine zentrale dass ich ein
Zentralregister habe wer ist alles
Mitglied und so dann wird kein Mensch
Mitglied werden das wird nicht
stattfinden aber wir arbeiten wirklich
also fleißig ich hoffe aber dass ich
sagen kann wir sind auch nicht dumm also
dass wir überlegen schon also ich habe
ja vorhin von diesem Dilemma gesprochen
ich glaube das ist jetzt auch an der
Diskussion irgendwie klar geworden ich
es bleibt schwierig und ich erinnere
mich an einen Satz von ihnen auf die
Frage und auf den Vorwurf dass sie
Minderjährige dann sozusagen weiterhin
in die Arme von Wieland treiben sagen
ich glaube sogar hier bei uns in der
Sendung
Dealer werden an den 17-Jährigen nicht
abhängig machen weil sie wissen dass ihn
als 18-Jährigen dann wieder verlieren
das stimmt ja das ist und der kann
keinen wirklich überzeugendes Argument
das Geschäft und den Deal dann wenn ein
machen kann ja genau jetzt wollte ich
das Argument erläutern und bevor ich die
Gelegenheit habe kommt schon vorab die
rhetorische Figur das was das Argument
was Jesus gar nicht mehr bringen werden
ist kein gutes Argument also das ist
durch also muss mehr kommen heute aber
die muss noch mehr kommen die ganze Zeit
immer in der Semantik weil die anderen
Argumente so furchtbar dünn sind das ist
doch doch das ist nicht die das ist auch
ein sehr interessanteratorischer Kniff
habe ich selten gehört so aber man
versuchen das ist sicherlich nicht der
Eindruck des Zuschauers der mir hier
wichtiger ist ist Moderators aber was
hier also läuft ist doch folgendes wenn
der Schwarzmarkt insgesamt kleiner wird
weil es ist diese genossenschaften gibt
dann ist allein die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass ich es mit einem Dealer zu tun habe
geringer ob ich Junge der alt bin weil
es weniger Dealer gibt somit muss ich da
gar nicht kompliziert werden soll ich
kann einfach statistisch rechnen der
Schwarzmarkt wird kleiner es gibt die
Genossenschaft so und das Modell ist ja
auf das spanische angelegt da ist der
Schwarzmarkt geringfügig kleiner
geworden plus dass man diesen Clubs auch
konsumieren darf und dort normal
verkauft wird das also System der
Spanier ist nicht das was wir nachahmen
weil all das was wir jetzt machen die
also Offensive Kampagne wie gefährlich
ist das wie gefährlich ist der Konsum im
Alter von bis und so weiter und so fort
und dass man eben der Cannabis
konsumiert ja aber wenn ich in den Club
z.B also selbst konsumieren will dann
kommen Leute zusammen die den Club
plötzlich aus einer soziale Gelegenheit
sehen und dann kiffen um mit ihrem Kopf
zu sein das ist das Hauptargument das
habe ich dagegen bin dass man in den
Clubs kiffen kann ich bringe es mal
simpel zwei Burschen kiffen toll vier
Mädchen finden diese Woche super dann
sagen die zwei treffen uns auch im Club
dann sind nachher zwei andere Mädchen
also auch haben also somit die Clubs
sind eigentlich
dass die Clubs also sozusagen eine
Gelegenheit hält
also die Leute werden ganz in den Club
gehen weil dann muss man ja erstmal
damit und dann ist da jemand der
präventiv sagt hey bevor du das kaufst
oder hier hängt ein Plakat du kannst
daran verrecken weil du eine Psychose
hast etc also jetzt mal hoch gezeichnet
aber das ist doch nicht attraktiv für
die Leute
somit ist schon mal ganz klar dass der
Club kann attraktiver Ort ist zu kiffen
weil das dort gar nicht geht 8 Euro ja
aber ich wieso denn wenn ich zu Hause
kiffen will und kriege hier gesicherten
Stoff und muss sonst über den schleichen
und gehe an denen hatte Prenzlauer Berg
ja also ja zum Beispiel kam mir von
ihnen ich habe den konnte ja nicht
gebracht sonst hätte ich ein Beispiel
aus meinem Wahlkreis gebracht aber das
habe ich auch ein Beispiel gut dann
können wir uns da auf den Wiener Platz
einigen also das also dann
die Szene sehr genau
und dann kann ich beim Beispiel bleiben
wenn sich den Wiener Platz anschauen und
schauen sich dort die Diele an wenn Sie
eine Alternative hätten also sagen wir
qualitätsgesichert zu kaufen ohne uns
wer geht denn dann noch zu dem Dealer
und weder Platz zu mir hängt